I need to start this video off on a sad
note on New Year's Day I lost my father
unexpectedly at the age of 57 he lived a
good full life but I just want to remind
everybody to enjoy the time you have
with your family because it can end
before you know it I'd like to say thank
you to everybody who supports this
project and I look forward to bringing
you a whole bunch of awesome resources
in 2018 to kick things off I'm going to
give you a quick angular productivity
booster to eliminate long relative paths
that look like this to a single global
namespace this means you can give all of
your feature modules a specific
namespace and you never really have to
worry about relative paths within your
project to demonstrate this I'm starting
off in a brand new angular 5 app and I'm
going to generate a couple of ng modules
first one being Corps second one being
shared from there I'm going to generate
a service inside of the core module
we'll just go ahead and call this the
off service then I'm going to generate a
component but for no reason at all I'm
going to nest this deeply within the
file structure of the project let's go
ahead and call it the deeply nested user
login component then if we look at the
file structure on the left you can see
the actual component file itself is
nested about six levels deep within our
project this isn't really a problem
unless we need to import this file in a
different file that's nested higher up
so let's try this by importing the
service into the component just a quick
side tip here whenever you import a file
in typescript start with empty
parentheses then type out the path so
you can use typescript autocomplete from
your IDE and save yourself a few extra
characters of typing at this point we're
going to have to traverse up the file
structure so we do dot dot slash a whole
bunch of times until we finally get to
our core module then we go in there and
grab the off service if you're an
angular developer you probably get
really annoyed if you have to do this
frequently in a large complex file
structure it also becomes a problem if
you change the file location because
you'll have to go back and rewrite each
individual path that references this
module and it's also a problem when the
imports are reversed if we were to
import the component in the service we'd
have to write out the end
tire deeply nested paths fortunately
typescript gives us an easy solution to
eliminate this problem altogether before
I show you the actual solution I want to
show you the end result so instead of
the dot dot / path that we have here
we're going to namespace the auth
service so that we can reference it from
anywhere in the project without dealing
with the relative path in this case it's
our core module so we'll namespace it
with at core an added benefit is that
the import statement looks exactly the
same throughout your project so you can
easily do a find and replace if you
change the name or location of the
imported file we can follow the same
pattern for our component but this time
we'll namespace it with shared instead
of core the only thing you have to watch
out for is name collisions so you
wouldn't want a namespace anything with
angular or ngr X or any other common
mono repo out there to make this
possible
all we have to do is make some updates
to our TS config in the root of our
angular app inside of the compiler
options object we're going to first set
a base URL which will point to the
source directory from there we'll use
typescript path mapping to give paths
relative to this base URL their own
custom namespace the @ symbol is
completely optional but I think it helps
make it stand out from regular imports
each namespace will point to a directory
within your project so in this case
we're just pointing to the core module
then we'll do the same exact thing with
the shared module but since we have that
deeply nested in there we'll use those
deeply nested paths as well and while
we're at it another really useful path
to namespace is your angular environment
the environment paths are always really
long so we can just give that its
namespace and never have to worry about
the relative path again and again you
want to be careful of name collisions so
if you want to be extra careful prefix
everything with the name of your app
that's it for my short imports video if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you're serious about
building apps with the stack consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase comm you'll get a free copy of
my book as well as exclusive access to
my upcoming full statics strike payments
demo thanks for watching and all
see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]